good morning john in amongst the set of
amazing analytics that alexander daly
put together there was some
there were a couple of actually pretty
big surprises but the biggest one
is he did an analysis to see which of us
said
more words per video he did this using
the transcripts on the nerdfighteria
wiki they're like 600 on there for each
of us then he averaged the number of
words we say per video and you
said 759 words per video and i
said on average 759
words per video i don't know if this is
gonna seem that weird
to people who aren't me but it seems
extremely weird you probably don't think
a ton
about how we make vlogbrothers videos
but most vlogbrothers videos since like
2010 have been
scripted so you write a script and i
make my scripts like around 650 words
long
because i know that that's gonna make a
four minute video and then the script is
over there and i use it as a guideline
and i don't really know how many words
actually end up saying but apparently i
end up saying about 110 more words than
are in the script i did not know that
until literally today and it seems that
you have settled on a similar strategy i
don't know what your strategy is but i
know that we're both trying to get the
most information into a four minute long
video possible so it seems
kind of likely that we'd end up with
similar numbers at the end but exactly
the same
indicates more than just trying to
achieve the same goal
it means that we're trying to achieve it
in the same way we've settled into a
pace of speech
that is exactly nearly exactly the same
i am entirely aware that we built this
channel together that
it's content its community its projects
are all an amalgam of you and me and
also the people who are watching
the stuff all put together but i've
still somehow like imagined this whole
time that what you do and what i do are
pretty different as an example when we
were on the turtles all the way down
tour you told me about your idea for
like raiding different facets of the
human-centered world on a five-star
scale and i made a video called hank
reviews everything where i review
traffic cones and socks and a half-empty
bottle of fiji water in a thermostat
in four minutes and then i never thought
about that again whereas your version of
that idea was years of carefully
constructed elegant podcasts followed by
a deeply introspective book that is as
much comedic memoir as it is historical
exploration i was like bang my bang i'll
do this idea
and i'll be done with it and you were
like let's spend some time here despite
what i said in my last video we're not
the same people and i think
what makes vlogbrothers so cool is that
we experience the world in very
different ways but we share a lot of
values but this has made me realize that
there's more to it than that you and
i influenced each other so much in how
we create these videos
that it is very true to say that neither
of us created the form of the
vlogbrothers video
we did it to each other so much so that
we say
on average the exact to three
significant figures the exact same
number of words will this video have 759
words
yeah almost certainly not but you can't
see reality with just one data point and
when you put all the data points
together you get a really specific story
the way that we did this
and it was not intentional makes it so
that everything you make
is also very much a thing that i made
and everything that i make is also very
much a thing that you make
you can see the collective nature of
this project
in the data but john what i thought was
an idea for a four minute video
you thought was something a lot more
than that and it has become a deep and
peculiar and captivating and hilarious
book and there are things happening with
it some cool folks have put together the
anthropocenereview.com which allows you
to take a picture with the book in a
place and also rate that place on a five
star scale so far it's just you and me
on the site but i imagine soon there
will be more
you're also going on a virtual book tour
may 17th 18th 19th and 22nd you can pick
your date based on which
store you live closest to or which guest
host you'd like to see the most tickets
to the events come with a copy of the
book and you can either have that
shipped to you or you can pick it up at
one of the partner stores you can find
out more about all of this at the links
in the description and as i have said
before but you can't say it enough the
anthropocene reviewed by john green
comes out may 18th and all copies will
be signed mine is
john i'll see you on tuesday